how's it going everybody
this is the reuben report direct message
for january 12 2021
a lot of twos and ones in that date um
there's a lot going on in the world in
case you didn't know i'm gonna try to
get you through some of it without
making you insane
no guarantees you know you should
probably have a lawyer next to you if
you think i'm guaranteeing that because
i don't know that i can guarantee not
making you
more insane but i'll do the best that i
can uh i should tell you guys that i'm
operating on about an
hour's sleep because i was on fox and
friends this morning
at i guess like 505 a.m pacific time so
i had to be up at 4
30. but you know sometimes when you set
your alarm for like a super early
wake-up
like you got to go to the airport or
something and then you just like can't
quite
sleep right and you're waking up every
15 minutes like how much more time do i
have oh i have seven more minutes very
exciting
so i was up basically from like two and
i went to bed at 10 i probably didn't
fall asleep till about midnight so i got
about two hours sleep here i've had like
just
endless endless meetings because of
locals because there's a ton of good
stuff going on which i'll get to in just
a second
um and then of course you know
everything that we've been talking about
on this show for years
it's like all happening right now which
is quite bizarre
you know the simple truth is and i'm not
i'm genuinely not saying this to pat
myself on the back i wish i was wrong
but all the stuff that i've been talking
about for five six years now about free
speech
about big tech about the ever
encroaching
movement to crush any idea that doesn't
fit
orthodoxy it's all here right now like
in many ways
not to be alarmist i genuinely don't
mean this to be alarmist i'm just going
to tell you how i feel about things at
the moment
doesn't it kind of feel like we're in
the middle of a slow
coup like we're in this like slow motion
coup
we don't really know who's taking over
i'm not saying joe biden then the
democrats are doing a coup
let's be clear hello media matters you
losers uh but that it feels like
everything is being taken away from us
every bit of rational thought
every bit of sort of functional
institutions
i can't imagine having kids right now
and sending them to public school like
that doesn't work i would never want
i don't want anyone in my family or
friends or anyone i love to watch
mainstream media that's a problem
so it's just like this ever moving
blob basically that feels like it's just
encompassing america you know what it is
it feels like the pink slime remember
the pink slime from ghostbusters 2
that was causing everybody to hate
that's sort of where we're at at the
moment i feel like america
is covered in pink slime and
you know where are the ghostbusters when
you need them because that's what we're
going through right now
and you know we're all in it together
and we're just watching so many people
you know
twitter has gotten and i would say the
general tenor of the major
tech platforms have has gotten much
worse you know if the idea was we're
going to ban
people and that's going to get us to to
heal like i think that has sort of
uh failed epically so everybody's kind
of just
just getting nutty and we haven't even
had the inauguration yet and
it's just it's just wild out there so
that's actually a perfect segue to the
to the first story that i want to talk
about so in case you've been living in a
cave
for the last few days uh donald trump
who still
is the president of the united states
believe it or not
he has been banned from pretty much
everything okay trump has been banned
from reddit he has been banned from
twitch
he has been banned from shopify he has
been banned from twitter
he has been banned from youtube he has
been banned from facebook he has been
banned from instagram he has been banned
from snapchat he has been banned from
tick-tock he has been banned from
pinterest he has been banned from stripe
and he has been banned from google and
apple uh which uh you know the stores
which also banned parlor can we confirm
absolutely confirm that he's been banned
from youtube
because that one i did not know um so i
want to just double check on that one
but basically if donald trump wants to
listen to music he can't do it on
shopify anymore if he wants to uh post
a picture of his latest uh you know
cap that he knitted he can't put that on
pinterest anymore he can't you know
do anything oh god it's just you get it
guys like
is this is this making us more tolerant
or not that is not a commentary on what
happened
the violence again should be a hundred
percent
condemned you know i'm also seeing a lot
of people that are saying trump was
calling for violence
even even people in my circles who i
sort of respect or at least
respected at one time saying that donald
trump uh
absolutely was calling for violence the
day before and he he repeatedly said
peaceful now
i guess the issue is if you're going to
tell people that the election is stolen
and get them to d.c
all riled up like what do you think is
going to happen but that's that's sort
of that gray area that we need
free speech for like a direct call for
violence is one thing
uh but dancing around dancing around it
is not
we're just in a weird thing oh all right
i was correct
i don't even have to correct myself uh
because i was correct actually
uh in my in correction and then i
corrected myself on the fly
uh youtube is the only big social media
service keeping trump's account open
for now but of course many people are
calling for it to be deleted
so that's interesting like out of all of
them they've left his
youtube up which is which is very
strange because as you guys know in
in the last couple weeks there's been a
whole bunch of messaging out of youtube
you know if you say this about the
election you can be banned we're going
to give you a strike we might just
delete
your channel altogether and you know for
someone like me or for any of the people
that you like on youtube you know when
they come in
with these edicts and again it's their
terms of service they're entitled
to do what they want the issue is that
it can become very hard
to communicate information to you guys
because what if i
slightly say something even if i don't
mean it or i'm just exploring an idea or
thinking something through
or whatever it might be doing a little
thought experiment talking about
uh censorship talking about the election
whatever it is and then someone at
youtube that
that doesn't like me and i have no doubt
that there's some people at youtube that
that don't like me i am a radical
freedom extremist after all
uh you know that they could just you
know click the button and and blow up
the whole thing
so uh as i said before this idea
that somehow if if we just start banning
people
put let's just remove trump from the
equation altogether right because trump
trump is is you know a special thing
let's say
um if we just remove trump from the
equation altogether it's like do you
think that these bannings
and saying you can't be on these things
you can't listen to music
through spotify you can't sell three uh
you know sell items
merchandise through shopify do we think
that this is actually going to make us a
more tolerant society
and do we think it's going to stop with
trump so let's say okay now we just
start
saying trump's supporters in general
can't do these things
well what what defines a trump supporter
is it did you have to be out there at a
mag or rally and are we gonna
go into old videos and find all the
people at rallies and should all of
those people be banned from things
and what about uh say a trump a tepid
trump supporter four years ago
who became a never trumper if they're a
never trumper now
do they have you know enough of a window
that they you know can bow to you for
but they did support him the first time
something like that
like there's so many versions of this
and and for all of these people that are
cheering it on
i hate to tell you guys but look at
history it
will come for you at some point and and
even beyond all that that we have
as i said the other day this this super
structure that now seems to exist
over the government like what seems what
seems
more powerful right now right at this
very moment
is it trump the president who really has
no way of communicating us apparently he
can put videos on youtube but he hasn't
and i have no doubt
like is there any doubt that if trump
put a video up on youtube right now
they'd ban him immediately like they
obviously would
so what feels more powerful to you
powerful to you the sort of
neutered president that we have okay
who who i actually fully believe that by
the end of after the stop the steel
thing and the republicans ted cruz and
josh halley and a couple others would
have voiced their opinions
on january 6 they would have you know
registered their complaints about the
election
and then that basically would have been
it i think that that's really
um what most sane people think like that
that would have been
it right um but what do you think is
going to happen do you think that you
can remove
all of these people from society and and
that
group of people that you will remove
from society will always be growing so
for now we'll say okay it's trump
supporters
but then it'll be more broadly
conservatives and you know who you can
see that's really excited about this now
it's like
the sort of never trumpers the kind of
like flaccid pathetic get everything
wrong republicans who never accomplish
anything
although occasionally help get us into
wars like bill crystal
and david frum that that type and the
the lincoln project guys
it's like they're loving this right now
because they're opposition they hated
trump right
so that's been destroyed and now they
can become just sort of nothing
think tank people who will be pet on the
head
by msnbc that's a conservatism that the
mainstream likes like oh
you guys you're all sort of failed
things from
from administrations that are long gone
right
but now you sort of pretend that you're
conservatives and we can just keep you
here as a little pet
there uh who is the guy that uh not who
was the guy that sat next to
jabba the hutt the little character he
sat next to jabba the hutt he was his
little pet what the hell was that guy's
name
crumb or something help me here somebody
get this uh that's what they want to be
right like they want just a bunch of
pets salacious crumb
was that his name salacious crumb that
sounds right to me but that seems to
salacious crumb somebody help you oh he
was a
kawakian monkey lizard with a shrill
cackle his name was salacious crumb
and he sat on jabba's deus stealing bits
of food and mimicking the hut
uh for all his visitors okay
so do you see my point i think i made a
fairly clear metaphor there
anyway guys this stuff isn't going
anywhere and i just want to quickly
address something that i said yesterday
because you know i had tulsi gabbard on
the show
and you know a lot of people felt this
was sort of the same democrat i i have
so many
viewers and listeners who are
conservatives
libertarians sort of reforming dems
whatever you want to call
me us at this point right and all of
them are going well that's the type of
democrat i could have went for and the
and the democrats had a choice joe biden
had a choice although again i don't
think he's really in charge but there
was a choice to be made like who do we
pick as vp
which which road do we want to go down
right now
do we want to go down a kind of centrist
genuinely pro-america let's listen to
each other let's have moderate positions
on abortion and let's not fully go down
the road of identity politics and let's
scale back the wars and all those things
that was the tulsi road they went with
the kamala road
um and yesterday when i had tulsi on
we obviously launched her her locals
community so it's tulsi.locals.com
and just real quick sales pitch real
quick we are building
a bottom up internet it is not like big
tech
i genuinely believe this and this is why
i started this company
two years ago and why i've put so much
blood sweat and tears into it
i always felt that this day was coming
and that the big structures
just like big government doesn't work
big tech doesn't work we don't need
our these overlords right at twitter
jack at twitter
and zuckerberg at facebook we don't need
these overlords telling us
who can talk and who can't now that
doesn't mean that every
platform and every place of the internet
should have people calling for violence
and terrorism and everything else
obviously
you can't do that on locals we're gonna
have a zero tolerance policy for it and
if you do that that's a that's a law of
the united states
you're breaking the law of the united
states and it will be it will be dealt
with but the idea
that the tech companies which are our
modern ways of communication right
they're the information highways that
allow us to share ideas
well we have the first amendment that
means the government can't come get you
but they're basically outsourcing it and
now what's happening is the tech
companies are saying okay these are the
things you can't say
so the in in a weird way we're like
putting the first amendment aside it's
like the government's not coming
for you for a lot of this stuff although
i think that's on the way we'll get to
some stories on that in a little bit
so our promise with locals is that we're
building digital homes for everybody if
you just want a home
that is yours online that you can set
some rules by
set a tone around conversation have your
videos and your audio and all that
please go to locals.com
and and create a community and by the
way because it's a paywall
uh because i think the days of the free
internet are over you know like
all of this stuff for free i was
thinking about it last night it's like
if you want new sneakers do you get free
sneakers you don't you have to pay for
them
you want a new phone do you pay for it
you pay for it you want a new mug do you
pay for it you want a new sharpie
you want some new paper you pay for it
we pay for everything
that's what value is that's what
capitalism is and we pay for something
in exchange to get something we want
and with big tech and all of these
things i know it seems weird but we just
decided to give ourselves over
and we didn't pay for it with money but
we paid for it with our souls and that's
why we're in this situation that we're
in right now
so i believe that the future of the
internet will be
smaller gated communities that will
figure out how to network with each
other
we'll have local control and local
rules around language and everything
else in my
reuben report community
reubenreport.locals.com you can you can
say whatever you want but as i said you
can't
there are no threats of violence you
can't post copyrighted material
or porn and by the way if people came in
there to just be awful
right like like virtually everyone is in
on twitter and all these other places
it's like well either you're paying me
as the creator for it
or i'll just boot you but if i boot you
that's like kicking someone out of my
house
that's not like kicking someone out of
the country where right now it's like
you get booted off all these platforms
so i just
firmly believe and i hope you guys
doesn't matter whether you join locals
or not or whether you join the reuben
port community or not
i just hope you will rethink your
relationship
with big tech because these companies i
don't think they're inherently evil like
i don't think they were born out of the
evil primordial ooze to come and destroy
all of us
but there's something about us that that
lends itself
to creating giant evil structures it's
why i've always feared big government
i think it's it's probably why you do as
well these big structures they're just
not inherently good and that right now
they in in this crazy time where it
feels like america
is hanging on by a thread democracy
feels weird the western world
feels weird all the good things we've
been taught about true equality and
freedom
feel like they're all in the balance
it's like we've got this group this
unnamed group of big tech people who are
telling us
who who we can and can't talk to and
what we can and can't talk about
and they're also saying it's not just
what you can say on our platforms but if
you go
somewhere else in this case parlor we're
just going to blow up the servers
now that is not again i hate having to
qualify this stuff but we live in such a
stupid time
that is not to defend any of the violent
threats that were made on parlor and
they were
which is by the way the idea of of
selling
something as a purely free speech
platform is a
is a very dangerous slippery slope and i
think i i
briefly discussed that privately with
dan bongino once dan magino of course
was the creator
of is the creator of parlor but i don't
that's why i don't
brand it's not just up to me but i don't
brand locals that way that it's purely
free speech it's that i'm trying to give
you the tools
to have to have a something a digital
something a home
that is in line with your values and
your beliefs i just think that's a much
better
way of doing things and and we got to
figure out how to deal with this stuff
and it ain't going anywhere
and i'm going to keep talking about it
as long as the youtube gods let me talk
about it but i will let you know that we
are working on live stream video for
locals which
uh i don't know if my developers want me
to say this but we should have in about
three weeks there we go guys work a
little harder okay
uh all right so i want to get to a
couple other stories because believe it
or not there's other things going on in
the world that i think
are worth noting but before we do that i
want to talk to you guys about gabby
insurance you know we're all looking for
ways to save money right now
and i want to ask you this how do you
like to keep an extra 961 dollars a year
in your pocket
that's how much gabby customers save per
year on average on car and home
insurance
gabby takes the pain out of shopping for
insurance by giving you
an apples to apples comparison of your
current coverage
with 40 of the top insurance providers
like progressive nationwide and
travelers
just link your insurance account and in
minutes you'll be able to see quotes for
the exact same coverage you currently
have
it's fast and it's easy and gabby can
show you if you've been overpaying
i discovered great deals as well as new
insurance companies and it was quickly
i was quickly able to compare the top
five rates by seeing them listed in
order
which made navigating through the plan
super easy
like i mentioned earlier gabby customers
save 961 bucks
per year on average i bet that'd be nice
to have in your pocket right now that's
more than six hundred dollars that the
government's giving you
if they can't find you savings they let
you know so you can relax knowing you
have the best rate out there and they
never sell your info
so no annoying spam or robo calls
you're probably overpaying on car and
home insurance see how much gabby can
save you it's totally free to check and
there's no obligation go to gabby dot
com slash ruben that's g-a-b-i
dot com slash reuben gabby.com reuben
and now back to me all right let's move
away from big tech for a second let's
move away
uh from trump for a second let's talk
about
the future the joe biden future of
america
where so many of my good liberal friends
said dave
you alarmist you extremist don't worry
dave
everything's going to be fine with old
joe biden he's not
a radical lefty he's a decent
america-loving liberal and it's going to
be okay and i kept saying guys
i don't think so as i've what what
analogy have i used here
he's but the host for the evil alien to
burst forth
and we are starting to see that alien
burst forth
uh here's video from the biden harris
presidential
transition team from a speech that joe
biden gave
two days ago and when we talk about woke
well
here's some woke on steroids for you
our focus will be on small businesses on
main street
that aren't wealthy and well connected
that are facing real economic hardships
through no
fault of their own our priority will be
black latino asian and native
american-owned small businesses
women-owned businesses
and finally having equal access to
resources needed to reopen and rebuild
but we're going to make a concerted
effort to help small businesses in
low-income communities
in big cities small towns rural
communities
that have faced systemic barriers to
relief
think of the mom-and-pop owner with a
couple of employees
joe uh let me make this a note directly
to you
not only is that racist that is
systemically racist
you are putting racism in the system
saying we are going to give to these
people based on their race based on
their skin color
based on their national origin we're
going to do that
which means we are going to not do it
for these people who may be in the exact
same economic hardship situation
that is racism that is 180 percent
on the dime the reverse of what martin
luther king jr said
what did martin luther king jr say he
didn't want his children to be treated
judged on the color of their skin but on
the content of their character okay
we all know it we all know it and we all
know that's right
we all know that's true liberalism we
all know that that's connected to the
american dream we all know that that's
what equality is
and joe biden i'll read it for you in
case you missed it
our priority will be black latino asian
and native american-owned small
businesses women-owned businesses
and finally having equal access to
resources needed to reopen
and rebuild okay now first off asian
that they put asian in there seems
extremely odd because we know that asian
americans generally regardless of
whether they're japanese chinese
or whatever it might be generally are
doing extremely well socioeconomically
but i think what you can see
the democrats doing is going oh if we
can just get them to think that they're
somehow a persecuted
minority that they'll keep coming with
us and it's a pretty good thing because
then it's like oh they're going we're
going to get more money by being with
them
but it's actually an erasure of of the
way asian americans have lived in
america which is
a tremendous amount of hard work caring
about education and family and
everything else
our priority this is what systemic
racism is when i've said for the last
couple years that the anti-racists are
the new racist
this is it please show me a policy that
evil donald trump wanted to push through
that was going to benefit one group of
people based on the color of their skin
at the expense
of other people i don't know what policy
that is but joe biden is telling you
we are going to have racist policies
women own businesses have women
been hit more by kovid than men i think
at one point i saw that
it was significantly higher male death
now often
women are married to men and they might
be upset about that maybe it's because
of that i don't know
i mean none of this makes sense but you
must understand we are in a deluge
of epic nonsense from these people this
is
i mean it's all here it's all here like
we're we're in it
it's wrapped all over us it's the pink
slime it's everywhere and it's insane
but if you think it's if you think
that's not insane dave you're
you're just you're just being crazy dave
would you please just calm down
well tucker carlson did a piece last
night on
kristen clarke who is joe biden's choice
to be the department of justice's civil
rights division
uh leader the head of the civil rights
division
and he did an incredible take down of
her it's about a minute and a half i
think it's worth watching and then we'll
we'll unpack it kristen clarke is joe
biden's pick to run the justice
department's enormously powerful civil
rights division
clark says her job is simple it's to end
hate but like so many in her world
clarke is in fact an enthusiastic
purveyor of what she claims to fight
clark's been on the show several times a
new investigation though by our
reporters has uncovered shocking and we
don't use that word lightly legitimately
shocking statements
that clark made in public while at
harvard in 1994 clark wrote a letter to
the harvard crimson in her capacity as
the president of the black studies
association
clark wanted to explain her views on
race science
quote please use the following theories
and observations to assist you in your
search for truth regarding the genetic
differences between blacks and whites
end quotes you know it's going to be
interesting and it was quote
one dr richard king reveals that the
core of the human brain
is the locus corulius which is a
structure that is black
because it contains large amounts of
neuromelanin which is essential for its
operation
two black infants sit crawl and walk
sooner than whites three carol barnes
notes that human mental processes are
controlled
by melanin that same chemical which
gives blacks their superior physical and
mental abilities
four some scientists have revealed that
most whites are unable to produce
melanin
because their pineal glands are often
calcified or non-functioning
pineal calcification rates with africans
are five to fifteen percent
asians fifteen to twenty five percent
and europeans sixty to eighty percent
this is the chemical basis for the
cultural differences between blacks and
whites
and five melanin endows blacks with
greater mental
physical and spiritual abilities
something which cannot be measured based
on eurocentric standards
end quote
all right thank you tucker for handling
that one for me i had to i normally
don't play like
so much of one clip from another show
but it's like you need to hear all that
you need to hear all that this person is
going to be the head
of the civil rights division does that
seem like a problem
you kids out there you often say the
phrase problematic that's problematic
that seems problematic to me the best
part of course was right at the end
that melanin uh actually gives you
special spiritual
abilities and i do want to say you know
i was in florida for 10 days and i i was
out there getting some sun and i did
feel i came back
and i felt more spiritual can i get an
amen
and an a woman you hear me people
we're in a lot of trouble we are in a
lot of trouble because not only
are they bringing back systemic racism
into our system by saying we're going to
help certain people based on the color
of their skin
but then we're putting people in
government who clearly have ideas based
in racial superiority that strikes me as
a problem
and let's just pretend for just a second
that this was a white person
saying those things about black people
right they would be banned they would be
de-person
they would be called racist and all of
those things now that's up for everyone
to debate all of those things
uh but the fact that this smoke
that that this is being this is being
unfurled
in front of us and it seems like the
smoke of the trump situation and the
social media situation
and that people are locked in their
houses and they're not going to work
it's like people aren't even really
paying attention to what's going on and
at some level i don't i don't blame
people so it is a very weird thing i
want to do one other story because it's
directly related to all this
uh very quickly uh there are two videos
we're going to show you them back to
back
from delta airlines from a couple days
ago where they've removed
trump supporters from a flight leaving
dc so this is af
this is after the capital event so these
are people leaving dc
who apparently were at the uh at the
rally as far as i know there's no reason
to think that they were violent in any
way
but they were on a plane leaving dc they
were
taken off a plane we'll watch that and
then the second video you're going to
see we're playing back to back is
is what happened right outside of the
gate once they were taken off the plane
why are they kicking off
freedom of speech
kick these people off the plane because
they support president trump
and you got all these standing around
doing nothing 30 cops over here
because they were waiting for these
people to get put off the plane
because they support president trump
in this country crazy
okay so obviously we don't have every
little bit of context to that but it
does appear that they were just trump
supporters on a plane you could hear
people on the plane
saying free speech free speech you could
see what happened after
after that let's let's just remove those
people
specifically but let's just talk sort of
broadly about what's happening here if
you say to people you can't be online
you can't go to work you can't have a
job you can't
afford things you can't get on a plane
the litany of things that we're seeing
here can't get on a plane you can't get
on a plane you can't get on a plane you
can't do any of this stuff you can't eat
you can't drink
what do you what do you think is gonna
happen what do you think people are
gonna do i mean that that's the problem
with banning people
and you know i have seen a tremendous
amount of
of people that years ago i thought were
my political allies
uh you know some some pretty big lefties
like sam harris
and stephen pinker and richard dawkins
uh now this is sort of a sidebar but it
is sort of interesting to me that
they're all well-known atheists
but i've seen all of them sort of
cheering on the fact that trump
got banned and once you start doing that
what you're saying is okay we should
also cheer on in effect i don't want to
put words in their mouths but in effect
you're also cheering on that his
supporters should be banned and of
course what that will do as i said
earlier was it'll be an ever expanding
list of people
that should be just taken out of polite
society but what do you expect to do
with these people like unless you want
to jail them and deport them and or kill
them
what what do you think should happen to
these people if the ideas
that they hold are so horrible and again
let's remove trump from this let's
remove trump as the main actor
and the main mover here if if you're
right
you tolerant liberals that these people
are so bad and they're enablers and all
of the horrible things
well then what is it that you really
think we should do with them
and this is how authoritarian regimes
rise this
is how the the bad ideas of socialism
and communism and state power rise
because
good people start looking around and
finding bad people everywhere and then
they never end up looking in the mirror
and and that really is the problem
so we really need to think through all
of this stuff um it it
as i said earlier it feels like
everything is under attack
and that ain't going anywhere for a
little while you know
i was not one of the people that said oh
goodbye 2020 2021 is going to be so much
better it was so obvious to me
that these divisions were only going to
get worse and now because of the
bannings and everything else that we see
they're going to increasingly get worse
i promise you i will try not to make
them worse
i don't know how you heal some of these
things and in many ways maybe we do need
some versions of a national separation
like the
the people that really support antifa
that really believe in identity politics
that really believe
in huge government like i don't really
want to live in the society they want to
live in and they don't really want to
live in the society i want to live in
now i'm not
saying we should be fighting i don't
want us to fight and i certainly don't
want anyone to be violent but maybe we
should figure out ways
and this is what localism is all about
right this is what federalism is all
about
that you go back to your local community
and those are the things that should
matter
and your family and your extended family
and the group of people around you at a
local level
because i think we're starting to
realize that after the advent of the
internet and 20 years of social media
we're realizing
that we have a tremendous amount of
people with a tremendous amount of ideas
and i'm okay
with people having different ideas than
me but a lot of people
aren't okay with having other people
have other ideas
this is a problem and i don't know how
that that becomes
a healing rather than an uh an
intractable problem so we we
have a lot of work that we got to figure
out um all right i got a whole bunch of
meetings
uh today about locals there's a lot
going on as i said
uh please check it out if if you haven't
yet i think we've got a little bit of
the answer
there's no answer that is purely
philosophically right legally right
technologically right yet but we're
working on decentralized storage
we're working on uh more diverse payment
processors
we're working on all of those things
we've cleaned up a lot of the
conversation
i think we've built something really
nice it's it's actually at least in my
community
reubenreport.locals.com we've built or
just reubenreport.com
we've built something that you won't
have a headache when you're there how
about that every time i open up twitter
i'm like oh
here we go again and it's it's just the
reverse the other way
uh i will be interviewing john bachman
who is
uh the early afternoon host on newsmax
who i do a show
once or twice a week i think he's just a
fantastic voice and
i'm glad that i can be sharing him with
more people i'm going to be doing that
later today and then we'll post it
later this week i'm also interviewing uh
patrick byrne
who is uh the ceo the former ceo of
overstock.com and a huge bitcoin guy
we're gonna talk all about big tech
and all of that stuff and uh if you
haven't checked out
uh tulsi gabbard's locals community
tulsi.locals.com and we've got a whole
bunch of
more announcements coming and everything
else okay
shut your computer shut your phone take
a walk have some water
goodbye